wait that doesn't sound right  rewind  the airplane has reached altitude and  the seat belt light turns off  all the passengers including you rise  from their seats the flight attendant  gives the signal and everyone jumps  as people's bodies leave the floor of  the cabin the plane loses 37  500 kilograms of weight  because the plane is lighter it will  rise in altitude as passengers leave the  floor  this sudden push of weight changes the  plane's trajectory and  nothing really happens  because the plane is traveling at around  870 kilometers per hour  this collective jump only created a  minor change in trajectory  the captain can easily adjust though he  may be a little annoyed at all his pesky  passengers